morning can you guys hear me up at the
end good good if I drift a little bit
and stays like quiet let me know so uh
my name is Luciano I work for IBM on a
group called coda which stands for
Center for open source data
nai technologies I've been working with
IBM for a little a little bit have been
working on open source for over ten
years did a lot of like Apache stuff and
in the past and more recently doing a
lot of things with the Jupiter ecosystem
working with notebooks we create an
enterprise gateway and we're working on
other projects as well if you need to
contact me have questions or need slides
or any anything related to the talk or
not here's all the information on how to
contact me email Twitter you can ping me
on github or or LinkedIn feel free to
take a picture I also going to put the
slides available so if you guys want
later on so just a very quick
introduction like when I talk about that
I work at IBM I think probably a lot of
people knows IBM but will probably think
about like maybe proprietary software
like mainframes and all of that I just
want to mention like we do a lot of open
source if we look into the project
products and services that we do today I
think pretty much all of those include
at least some kind of like open source
packaging and we contribute a lot the
numbers I have here like over like 10 K
commits per month that is probably much
much much bigger now that we have
acquired Red Hat so these this kind of
stats is like prior to red head
requirement and not only that I mean as
I'm today here like we do a lot of like
we go talk with the community try to do
the bridge from like requirements coming
from corporations and stuff so it's very
good to have a conversation be part of
the community give back and all of that
what do we do in open search so like a
lot of like the projects that we build
like maybe coming from research and
stuff particularly more
even more on the AI side we have been
kind of like starting to put those into
open source we have a place where we
kind of like well not necessarily
incubation place but like a place that
it goes into like developerworks website
called developerworks code a lot of like
the projects get started there and right
after that we start working with the
community building a community around
that and those start getting migrated to
maybe like open governance some examples
yes but not like just be really like
some examples like node-red open whisky
which is now at apache system ml
blockchain and among others and we keep
always like bringing more and more
projects into that place in terms of
community and contributions I think just
some examples here these are some of the
strategic communities that we have not
necessarily by any means only those we
do across the board open source
contributions and participation we also
have been teaching kind of like internal
like the IBM's like how to participating
in open source like what is the
implication of like choosing licenses
and all of those like very important
information we also have made those
available in open source like in the
developers website as well and last but
not least the my group Center for open
source the United Technologies a hundred
percent of what we do is with the
communities open source projects we
started a few years ago we were
originally called spark Technology
Center we increased the scope to go and
do more a is so we still have like data
as like all the contributions between
analytics a spark in that area but we
are now like doing a lot of like
contributions on tensorflow
pi torch cubes low and then you name it
I mean it's related to my group IBM does
a lot more other than that so I think
you guys really want to know more and
learn about like pipeline so today what
are we going to talk in terms of that a
little bit of like Jupiter and old
books as we kind of like just quit
everybody on the same page probably like
a lot of the a lot of you guys have
played with notebooks in the past well
okay a good a good percentage so we can
kind of like jump around some of those
talked about some of the analytics
workload some of the scenarios how you
start putting things into pipelines that
will touch base a little bit of like how
we get things into productions as well
and then when we move to more like deep
learning workloads they have kind of
like a different set of requirements and
we're just gonna see like how we build
that in a different set of like
environment and some of the tools and
and and frameworks that are available in
the market that we can use for those so
Jupiter notebooks I think you guys all
familiar with that it allows you to
start putting like code documentation
narrative all of that into one place
development is an interactive
development so you can focus and repeat
like a specific sales and get going and
going but really like why jupiter
notebook got so so kind of like
interesting in everybody or a lot of the
people already knows about that some of
the characteristics that we see on the
notebooks so it's very simple and
powerful you can basically bootstrap go
to the web page if you getting it as a
service even easier you just hit a web
page everything that you need to do
development is there it's interactive
you basically you can request some data
I start plotting that and and and
getting kind of like visual details
about the data data science I mean we
know that not of the data science
background they come from like computer
science they might come from different
backgrounds they might have different
like skills in terms of like or
preferences in terms of languages a lot
of people like are a lot of people like
Python data engineers might want this
environment but they like Scala or
something else
Jupiter notebooks provide all of that
the kernels give you a kind of like ice
isolation of the environment and you can
select which one kind of likes it
you better or you're more familiar with
so you're more productive for those
doing analytics integration with Big
Data is right there there are like
kernels that goes and talk to spark in a
very integrated with spark we saw task
presentation just before the 1b two
presentations before mine which were
basically describing like desk and and
and giving some of the examples as well
that you can be using as in in the
notebooks and once you kind of like have
that it's easy to just like maybe pack
that into a github repository or just
it's kind of like if you don't have a
lot of like dependencies on that in
terms of data just ship internet sent
via email the notebook everything is
there you can start sharing and
collaborating with a couple of folks
that you you have let's start now taking
a look of like some of the workloads and
how we can start actually building
pipelines for some of those workloads
and not necessarily having to kind of
like go away from the notebook and just
reuse the notebook what do we see when
we talk about analytics workloads so
like some of the characteristics here
large amount of data so you you need a
lot of like resources to to be
processing those usually those data is
kind of like a you have a like a data
lake or or like an object storage we
have those data available and some of
the kind of like a workloads that you
want to do some of the tasks you want to
do is start start start playing with the
data cleaning the data so that is useful
for you you can maybe start doing some
data warehouse applying some machine
learning to get some insights so in that
kind of workload like what are the
things that we that we want to do when
we are developing some analytics
workload usually what we see is people
really want to start decomposing those
like processing data or maybe like
cleaning the data is one of the tasks
that you need to do but you don't need
to do that very often maybe you need to
do when new data is coming or like you
need
but you can move to other parts of your
development pipeline and do interactive
development reusing the data that has
been processed processed so this kind of
gives you an example of like a different
stages that might consist pipelines and
that you might have a notebook that is
performing or executing some of those I
think depending on preferences or
different scenarios this might be much
bigger this might be much smaller so you
met you mileage will vary but it's just
as an example and to kind of like
concretely show you like what I'm
talking about we're gonna be using one
scenario for this talk and just for
folks what I did is I kind of like
create a scenario where I wanted to
collect some community stats from
repositories in like that I I kind of
like follow so I have a notebook that
goes and collect statistics such as like
Forks stars and a number of number of
contributors creates a CSV I have
another notebook that goes into a
specific repositories and see like the
amount of contributions that we are
getting and who are the top contributors
for example and then that generate
another CSV and I have an overview that
basically gives me kind of like a
visualization or something that is more
consumable by by me or by anyone that is
and I look into that so very simple
scenarios just starting from kind of
like early on if what I'm doing is very
simple and I don't need to like have any
big workflow there are some solutions
that are very easy to implement so let's
look into those and then I think that
the second part of the the top we're
gonna look more into like frameworks
such as air flow and tensor flow
pipelines so simple ways very simple
very easy to implement if you're using
ipython
ipython has a kind of like a run magic
you can basically use that run magic and
say execute my
two other notebooks that are generating
data and that will execute those and
then go and start executing the next
sales so you do have the very first
hello world pipeline in like two three
lines of code everything else the magic
handles for you some of the benefits is
easy to use limitations very kind of
like Python centric so if you're doing R
or doing something else probably that's
not gonna be available for you it's a
static you do that and that's all the
thing you do you don't have any
flexibility to say you only do this if
maybe the data file is not generated yet
or anything like that
there is no command line integration so
if you need to do some kind of like
scheduling or integration with something
else it's a little bit more harder but
you get simplicity or you you get more
kind of like capabilities but that can
gives us a kind of like initial step on
doing that and I'm gonna talk about
couple scenarios and then show it
working go back to kind of like a couple
more scenarios showing a demo instead of
like just one by one so that it it's
kind of like takes more time another
example another tool that we have and
that starts giving a little bit more
flexibility it's a and B convert and B
convert is a tool on on the notebook
side for from a creative from Jupiter
guys that I think initially the main
goal is to give you ability to you
getting a notebook convert that maybe to
HTML PDF or you name it all the
supported outputs are available here but
I think it's extensible and create your
own but one of the ways to convert those
is by executing those notebooks so you
can start kind of like a piping those or
putting together multiple notebooks to
generate a kind of like a pipeline that
will give us kind of like a similar
scenario with extra capabilities of
enabling us to convert the outputs maybe
to something that we can easily share
and also sort of like giving us the
command line integration capabilities
where we can start maybe like scheduling
that with cron jobs and things like that
so it starts giving you a little bit
more flexibility there just as an
example on how if you would use so you
can easily just do a people install and
be convert if you doing anaconda
probably everything is already their
life or if you just have notebook
installed it's probably you have that
there and you can just say again be
convert to HTML and then the - - execute
will force that notebook to get executed
and you can just get the output as an a
notebook itself or in into HTML or some
other format that you need so far so
good
ok people started using those where
maybe like not so flexible not so like
in integratable into other solutions and
then a couple years ago I think Netflix
open source papermill have you guys
heard or use the paper mill in the past
okay a couple of guys so paper meal sort
of like starts getting you the ability
to execute notebooks starts getting you
a little bit more flexibility enabling
it to like the fine and pass parameters
so you can actually run one notebook to
three times and say maybe this is
running on a dev environment this is
running on a production or maybe you're
trying to train a model and you pass a
set of parameters you're kind of like a
control the information you need to pass
to that model during training so we
start to give you that flexibility the
good thing is it also has sort of like a
kind of like API so you can start using
that programmatically and integrating
some other maybe application or even
other
book or just your Python script so that
gives you more flexibility you have
access to you kind of like generating
multiple runs multiple experiments with
with that in starts also making easy for
for scheduling and I think that was sort
of like a good step in the sense of like
building pipelines because after we got
that and after we got kind of like a
programmatic API we start seeing paper
mill sort of like being the basis to you
a lot of like the next example that
we're going to talk about where it then
was embedded into bigger workflow
enabling you to run a notebook directly
and get you don't have to kind of like
have to after you're done with notebook
transform that in like a Python script
or something else to to execute so so
far so good
just quick summary before we go to the
demos so what we heard what we learned
so far
running external notebooks from within
the notebook sales using paper mill
api's and kind of like being able to
convert those and run and convert those
to some other output that we need let's
see how it really looks kind of like in
action
[Music]
is it big enough people can see in the
back go so if you guys want to do it
together or later on for reference
everything is on my github so I just
using some of the gitlab so this is get
lab before those that are not familiar I
just used the git integration and I
check out my git repository the scenario
that we talked about is inside pipelines
folder so if I was doing if was going to
do this kind of like manually so I would
have kind of like the the stats here my
contribution and then I can have let's
say my overview here and I would go in
and execute here so run run all cells
and you start seeing that some CSV are
gonna start popping up on the Left
similar thing here let me run and then
in this case just manually let me wait
for those CSV is so the stats are there
okay and I can come here now to my
overview and then just run all sales and
I can see it's sort of like the kind of
like more visualization the the
repositories that I kind of follow some
stats there in like some of the
contributions on other repositories as
we saw like with the run very simple if
we want to automate that so I don't have
to go and like run every single one of
the repositories I can basically come
here you can see the run magic and I'm
just saying run these other notebooks
for me very simple to implement very
easy but not very flexible similar I can
just go and say run it will generate the
data again and I can get my kind of like
overview here so just taking a little
bit time and we can see the updates on
the last modified basically being
regenerated and once those can kind of
like have been implemented or run you
execute the rest one of the jackets as
well is like if you have big notebooks
that are running it kind of like I gonna
go in parallel I'm sorry it's not then I
go in parlor is gonna be sequential so
when you start using other frameworks
that we're gonna look into air flow and
queue flow pipelines you give you get
the parallel parallelism as well so that
multiple notebooks can running at the
same time and similar thing with the
paper mill integration now I can
actually just for example use the kind
of like API so I imported paper mill
package and I can do execute notebook or
I can actually just shell and use the
command line here and kind of get that
and then I use kind of like the env
convert here too
kind of like execute the overview in
actually even output like an overview
HTML for me so let me run those
and that's just wait so I've got it one
of those got executed the other is gonna
be kind of like in a shell you can see
it kind of like the percentage being
executed here and then right after that
we'll see kind of like the overview of
getting generated and we can actually
use that ok just executing and we can
see here that we should have it yeah we
have the overview here and this is kind
of like a snapshot and it converted to
HTML you can get that getting
information maybe ship by mail to your
boss or some other people that is
interested on that so very easy very
useful and you got kind of like a very
initial pipeline implemented here so
going back to presentations so far it
good so far so good any questions ok
challenges here is these are very good
very simple scenarios for us to get
started
see how we can kind of like start
getting those notebooks reuse it and
sort of like more towards generating
data but in when you talking about
enterprise the the this kind of like
solution doesn't have really like all
the requirements that we need to build
very big workflows and I'm talking to
you I'm talking really something like
that I mean it's like chains of like
maybe I'll close to 100 or maybe
sometimes even more kind of different
steps steps and needs to run in parallel
steps you maybe needs to kind of like
only run if something else happened how
do you start doing that in a kind of
like efficient way but also plugging
your notebooks not having to transform
that into like maybe a Python script or
some other application if we look into
just like if we take
The Notebook picture out of the out of
the the question here we have seen very
kind of like frameworks that have been
very successful in the market one is
Apache airflow we have been I mean I
think a lot of like this I Popeye datas
and stuff I see air flow being mentioned
other type of like conferences as well
and when what is air flow air flow
starts giving you kind of like a way to
programmatically similar to kind of like
how paper mill had an API air flow has a
kind of like work flow API that starts
you lets you start building tasks kind
of like based on operators to to build
your pipelines with your workflow and
then execute those so far so good we see
it handles very large workflows how do
we then kind of like stared start
incorporating notebooks so we the
notebook can become part of that
workflow so I mentioned kind of like a
this notion of operation that are used
to build the dag for for the air flow
there is a paper mill operator that
allows you to start bringing a notebook
as one of the steps of the air flow
workflow and you specified then which is
the notebook that you want to run you
can start passing for example parameters
and so forth all the capabilities that
that paper mill gives you kind of like
natively now it's in a Buhl's you to
just plug that as an operator into air
flow and what we saw in the example
where we just run a notebook now it can
be running as part of the big air flow
workflow so that gives us much more
flexibility much more powerful to
integrate and decompose our notebooks
and start reusing those into like more
enterprises analytic pipelines and
basically what we saw before in terms of
the workflow now just notebooks are part
of that just a quick summary on the
first pass here what
so for the analytics so what like just
kind of like a summary so like if you're
looking to run the run magic is mostly
Python and static and B converter I
starts giving you a little bit more in
terms of like support for different
kernels I did with more dynamic city
there paper mill is kind of like giving
you even more gives you programmatic
api's it enables you to start using it
notebook parameters and we've air flow
you start and kind of like tackling the
enterprise scenario being more able to
build easier genius pipeline workflows
okay so if no questions I will start
talking a little bit more of the AI and
deep learn workloads cool oh yes
so if if you're using run and you're
running a notebook the only way to
execute something different maybe
another notebook or with another
parameter you have to go to the notebook
and change that once you start having a
little bit more flexibility in terms
that's a programmatic API you might have
a cell that says how if the file is not
there like the data file that you're
looking for then run this notebook that
is going to generate that file so you
have more control without requiring to
go back and update your notebook to to
give that flexibility to you you are so
have you guys been doing deep learning
and kind of like tensor flow and other
API is around okay I feel but much less
than the guys that are familiar with the
notebooks so she made the main
difference from like analytics to kind
of like when you're doing deep learn
it's like analytics it maybe you're just
processing a lot of data most likely you
will be using some kind of like API but
it's not very complex environment in
terms of like maintaining that
environment you don't need a lot of
insulation but when you start going to
deep learning workloads you need a lot
of ease elation why if you look at let's
say I work in a company that does tensor
flow if you have four people probably
they are all in different versions of
tensor flow they have different
dependencies they one required two GPUs
others don't you have to really start
isolating the environment to give
flexibility for folks to do those and if
you expand to the different frameworks
then you have people are doing Python
are all of those different and it's very
hard to try to manage that in one
environment so isolating that is much
easier types of
things that you do also take a lot of
time like training sometimes like a very
simple minused it might take an hour we
have some models that we do that takes
like a week to Train so it's complicated
and you might not want to directly just
do that interactively but you want to
reuse the notebook there are a lot of
like a different requirements that comes
into play when you're done when you're
talking about AI and deep learning
workflows also I really want to think in
the kind of like a persona of the data
scientist a lot of the things that we do
today are to make that work maybe like
as we saw in some of the others involves
a lot of like a DevOps type of things in
in in the case of like doing AI model
development it's even worse how you do
research management how you handle
configurations okay I'm ready I'm gonna
do serving what I'm what I'm gonna use
to serve how do i scale that oh I'm
still in training on how I handle hyper
parameters do monitoring reproducibility
when once that is kind of like ready and
if the data science is not every time
comes from kind of like a CS background
and it's very hard to for us to try to
put that burden into the data scientist
so some of the challenges and I think I
just mentioned a little of those so how
do i isolate multiple environments
multiple frameworks all the frameworks
have different dependencies how do I
allocate and free up resources I I need
to give GPUs for given data scientist
not for others more data more memory how
easily to give those environments for
the data science to do their workloads
so what we have seen here containers
gives you a lot of days of isolation
kubernetes came to kind of like do the
management for those it allows you to
start kind of like giving an environment
as a flexible flexible
thing in the sense of like I can say oh
I need a Python kernel for my notebook
but I'm doing tensorflow so give me that
in a tensor flow image then I can start
kind of like attaching to that GPUs and
only for the time that I'm using because
that pod is gonna be kind of like giving
away back to the pool once I'm done with
that execution so that gives us a lot of
like flexibility in terms of like the
environment where to run it still not so
or the kind of like DevOps text that we
need to do what we start seeing to kind
of like help on the DevOps and not
necessarily help a hundred percent but
they are trying to get there is then
kind of like AI platforms we have seen
like a cube flow we as IBM we have like
Watson machine learning as well then
there are others that are coming up in
the market these are all kind of like
sort of like neo may be a couple of
years or frameworks or platforms that
are coming out and they really try to
focus what most of them and I think if
not all are based on kubernetes to
leverage all those kind of things we
discuss it and they try to kind of like
remove some of the DevOps making easier
for the developer that are building a
model to kind of like concentrate on
building the model and all of the DevOps
cubes so basically then kind of like a
ml to kit for kubernetes
has been there for a couple of years try
to help you there but I think what
really we want to talk about is sort of
like cubes or pipelines and the cube
flow pipelines enable us to start kind
of like defining those workflows that we
need but very centric to AI models so
you can have like end-to-end
orchestration it starts to do easy
experimentation so you define a pipeline
that pipeline can then run multiple
experiments with different parameters in
it starts to be kind of like easy to
reuse those pipelines then can be reused
or attach it to others
when we talk about pipelines the two
things kind of like you need to know
like the pipeline in itself we have a
visual representation here then is sort
of like packet by kind of like a mo file
that defines what kind of like each of
these components or tasks will need to
do in the environment that needs to be
used and each component basically each
task is a component and the isolation
that we mentioned the component is kind
of like associated with I give an image
that you need to do those cue flow
pipelines also have the notion of like
the operators and have kind of like a
programmatic SDK or API similar to air
flow so a lot of the concepts are
similar I my particular view air flow is
more for analytics type of like
scenarios cube flow pipelines because of
like the isolation being run on top of
kubernetes give you more like the
environment that you need for AI and
here is sort of like the code that we
need in kind of like a representation of
the pipeline from the two notebooks that
we are looking at let's take a look now
maybe it oh maybe I have a one more
slide here and then we can take a look
at concretely how it works and then take
a quick like view of like kim flow so
going back to the initial slide that we
were looking to the pipelines in AI and
with tube flow pipelines we start
enabling may be sort of like different
environments for different tasks that
the tasks that we want maybe I want to
do model training with tensor flow I
wanna GPUs associated model validation
of probably maybe let's say use tensor
flow as well but deployment I'm gonna
use like a different kind of like
environment I want to use native
kubernetes and creative server and
high-tone maybe to just kind of like I
do some model testing
after the fact so you start giving that
and you can build up that all into your
pipeline definition so questions I'm
gonna hop into kind of like the example
and that should give you a lot more let
me just shut down the previous ones
so if you don't have like let's say the
environment install people install KSP
we'll give you kind of like what you
need and I kind of like a defined here
so sort of like where in object storage
notebooks and some of the resources that
I need will be and then I start defining
kind of like the I kind of created a
notebook operator to simplify and ban
the definition of the pipeline here with
my the finding that I want one notebook
to be running and then I define kind of
like the the kind of like after means
the dependencies so I want the overview
to run after the other two have already
run and then the SDK basically and say
compile this pipeline and upload to the
environment so let's run this and see
how what we're gonna get
so executing let me go now and show okay
so we can see kind of like the pipeline
that got created here so like by the
timestamp and you can see the kind of
like each of each component here you can
see also like in the backend is kind of
like back at by a mo file and this is
just the definition you can click and
then see kind of like arguments that is
being passed and experiments actually
then is where you're going to execute
those pipelines in the notebook that I
submitted already kind of like created
an experiment in a specific run for
myself and we can see here some got
already executed and how the files are
there and being kind of like uploaded
that the results to object storage where
you can see and at the end you see those
you can go and then kind of like see the
results in in object storage we use
those or in that case I'm returning in a
version of a notebook that has been
updated and also a HTML conversion and
we are sort of like running getting
close to you the time so I'm just gonna
give you some of the resources in open
for questions
thank you very much for attending and
any questions Thank You Luciano thank
you talk so one question I guess I
mentioned so
so make I'm not sure if I understand
your scenario but like for make I
usually do and maybe I'm using it wrong
but like I usually maybe try to handle
more like a build type of like steps
automation this is trying to out of me
to certain exceed its automation as well
but I come it's more like the execution
so you might be running one of the steps
which is a notebook that is doing
training that might take four or five
hours in that batch kind of like
environment that cube flow provides you
so to a certain extent it's kind of like
the similar automation but not
necessarily to replace make but make my
might help you submit those jobs maybe
let's say two cubes all working for
pipelines you welcome another question
here oh sure
thank you very much